and is it better to be in a society that  stigmatizes  drug use or is it better to be in one  that just opens up the door and says  yeah do whatever you want  well you could stigmatize it and  criminalize it you're not going to get  rid of it we all understand that  but is it better to live in a society  where people are just literally laying  on the sidewalk  using drugs passing out overdosing  so you walk walking through a city means  you have to step over the bodies of uh  people of OD'd on God knows what  is that an improvement I mean that that  is what it looks like we've discovered  when you get rid of the stigma  and you also get rid of the legal  penalties on these drugs